[Music]
the assembly of national spirits
constitutes a circle of shapes which now
embraces the whole of nature as well as
the whole ethical world
they stand too under the supreme command
of the one rather than under
his sovereignty
by themselves they are the universal
substances of what the self-conscious
essence in itself is and does
this however constitutes the power and
in the first instance the center at
least with which those universal beings
are concerned and which at first seems
to merge their affairs only contingently
but
it is the return of the divine being
into
self-consciousness that already contains
the reason why self-consciousness forms
the center for those divine powers and
conceals their unity to begin with under
the form of a friendly external
connection of the two worlds
paragraph
728 is now helping to elaborate the
side of the divine of the gods in a
plurality but also with
you could say a certain kind of unity
although it's it's a
contingent and somewhat fragmentary
unity that is in the process of being
developed and what we see here is this
is helping us to understand what the
pantheon the all the gods referenced in
the previous paragraph
is actually going to look like in
relation to
human beings but here
in this paragraph as opposed to the the
next one
it's the totality of the divine
existences that is being elaborated
there's not a lot of discussion of the
relation to
human beings whether it be that of the
type of artist that miller is going to
translate in the next paragraph as the
minstrel or the heroes and kings and
other important peoples that are going
to get depicted in the first kind of
language the first kind of
artistry and poetry
that hegel is going to devote some some
serious attention to that of the epic
so what do we have we could call this in
a certain respect
the
ideology or the developmental
picture
of what the gods are and and this is
quite interesting because there is an
important
set of resolutions that are taking place
here so he says the assembly of national
spirits let's start with that assembly
for zomlung
this is not a complete unity this is not
an organic state or anything like that
this is a bunch of gods being put
together in some sort of association
national spirits here is not nazi and
all geyston right it's uh folk that is
being used for nation here
and
what should that mean for us well think
about the previous paragraph and this
process of bringing the different
national spirits together
into some greater unity politically and
that's going to be referenced here in
terms of
the rulership region that was referenced
in the previous paragraph with respect
to human rulers now
with respect to the gods not using that
term regul or ordnang as another another
term that was used but using some other
political language
so the assembly of the national spirits
he says
constitutes a circle a case of shapes
gestaltene
and this is very important which now
embraces
the whole of nature gans is the word
that's being used the totality if you
like
as well as that of the whole ethical
world and here he actually does use the
word
as well as right but he also uses the
term gun so we have two totalities
which are to some degree
overlapping we're gonna see that the way
it's depicted at first is not quite
so uh connected
necessarily connected but they do
overlap and each of these
is a world so this is particularly
important when we look at the very last
sentence when he says
[Music]
self-consciousness forms the center for
those divine powers conceals their unity
to begin with under the form of a
friendly friendly
external australica connection of the
two worlds what are the two worlds well
the world of nature
and the world
of the
we could call it culture the ethical
world the political world
these are connected with each other
but they're viewed as being kind of
sundered split apart external to each
other and we'll come back to that in a
moment so this assembly of the national
spirits
is a way in which these things can be
brought together
and we can take into account the
different kinds of functions that we
find in divine pantheons really not just
for the greeks but basically you know
across
religions in general if you look at
religions they are very often nature
gods gods that represent certain aspects
of nature so let's take you know ancient
greece right we got poseidon who's the
sea very important for seafaring people
right we have uh demeter who is the
goddess of grain and agriculture
generally
we have we could say hera as the
representative of generation pregnancy
motherhood all of those sorts of things
already though we're starting to creep
into the ethical world with that maybe
one reason why hera is so jealous is
because zeus is such a complete jerk
going around and and uh getting it on
with all sorts of other human women and
and forsaking his his wife when he want
not to do so um and we could talk about
dionysus and we could talk about other
nature deities as well
there are all sorts of deities uh sort
of minor ones of particular streams
there's the you know dryads and there's
all sorts of other things the winds
themselves are
semi-divine or divine depending on how
you look at it so we have
deities within this assembly
representing the natural world
we also
have deities representing the ethical
world the world of zita of morals
and it's not a complete unity um there's
there's actually you know if we take the
ancient greeks right we have two
different gods who have something to do
with war directly we have aries who
represents the destructive bloodthirsty
side of war we have athena who
represents strategy and they're both
essentially war gods right we have uh
artemis the goddess of the hunt perhaps
that's also nature but perhaps that's
also a distinctively human activity
we have apollo you know a god who
performed several different roles
prophecy the sun music
we could go on and on and then of course
we have zeus right who is the ruler of
this pantheon but kind of a
loosey-goosey ruler right he doesn't
often use his authority
and uh sometimes he's not obeyed
so
we have all of this and if we looked at
other
pantheons
in other
cultures we would find similar things so
just to take a few examples right if we
look at you know the vedic religion
there's all sorts of nature gods but
there's also varuna who represents order
right and there's also uh mithra who who
represents you know sort of defense uh
we could go on and on like you know
going from greece all the way up into
you know the the germanic into the hindu
iranian
into
going further uh east into china where
there's oh there's so many gods
that arise and we would find the same
thing
basically occurring
in every
complexly developed religious culture as
a matter of fact
even among
fairly nomadic
cultures we're going to find
much of this happening so
he goes on and he says they that's the
assembly of national spirit stand under
the supreme command
of the one in this case zeus rather than
under his sovereignty so this is an
interesting distinction supreme command
over befale
right a a command a
limited set of orders
order is another word for buffalo right
sovereignty over here shaft it's not
something
that is
institutionalized and made permanent all
you know once for all although you could
say well when is zeus going to lose his
his sovereignty well you know if one of
his kids
takes him out or something like he did
with his dad um which is which is a a
concern that he could have
or you know if the religion loses its
efficacy which is what happened
historically
um
why is hegel stressing this well this is
connected to that point that he was
making in the previous paragraph
about how it is that a common project uh
uh you know example handling brings them
together
and we could say that this is a common
project of keeping the cosmos
and the ethical portion of it as well in
existence and functional so he goes on
and he says
by themselves these these gods are the
universal substances of what the
self-conscious existence in itself is
and does now there's a little bit uh
that's been left out in the translation
here because
this
by
itself by themselves is actually
translating
for zeke right um the the
uh
for themselves for
it as opposed to the anzik right
so the in itself and
this is i think an important point to
make there's these are being brought
together and then he says this however
constitutes the power
and in the first instance the center
now center
um he's not saying zenthrome which would
be center
he's actually saying mittelpunct which
you can translate as center but given
the where we're going next i think it's
good to think of this as the
mediating point
the mean right um the middle the the
center he says at least with which those
universal beings are concerned
now this is important
what is constituting the center
the universal substance of what the
self-conscious essence in itself is and
does there's there's some unity
underlying this and it's a unity that's
being
not seen it's being
concealed it's being mistaken because
it looks like this assembly merges
there's affairs only contingently it
just happens to fall out this way that
you know let's think about for example
the story about how zeus became king of
the gods right um the three brothers
after they had gotten rid of their their
father and zeus was the youngest and you
know very instrumental in in that you
got got uh kronos to throw up
his consumed children uh three girls
three boys
the three boys
cast lots for who's gonna have what
thing and poseidon gets the c and hades
gets the underworld and zeus gets the
heaven and good for zeus
he's now the ruler right
that appears to be kind of just chance
but there is a sort of internal
necessity to this hegel is saying
so he says it is the return of the
divine being
into self-consciousness so these are not
just
figures in a story
they are themselves
self-conscious
at least this is how they're being
represented right zeus zeus is a
self-consciousness aries is a
self-consciousness aphrodite is a
self-consciousness and they engage with
each other as
self-consciousnesses do
in their story so he says the return of
the divine being into self-consciousness
that already contains
the reason why self-consciousness forms
the
center
middle point again
for those divine powers and conceals
their unity
to begin with under the form of a
friendly
external connection of the two worlds
nature and the ethical world are more
closely connected more intimately
connected
than we originally think when we
extricate ourselves at first from nature
and stand apart from it
we're perhaps on the side
in our late modernity many of us of
seeing too much of this side the ethical
world and sort of an
anemic version of nature because we
don't spend an awful lot of time
when i would talk to my
world religion classes when i first
began teaching
those classes one of the things that i
would sometimes do is counsel them to go
outside
and actually find a place where they
could look at the sky put their
devices away and just
take in the totality of what the heavens
look like and imagine
all these roads buildings cars not being
here
and being under the great dome of the
sky and thinking what it might be like
for ancient
peoples
thought experiment to try to carry out
that can help us to understand this
whole of nature part in a little way but
does it help us understand the unity
that he's talking about here not quite
yet but the unity is something concealed
at this point so everything here appears
to be contingency when really there is a
necessity ruling it
the same universality which belongs to
this content attaches necessarily also
to the form of consciousness in which
the content appears
it is no longer the actual practice of
the cult but a practice that is raised
not in not yet indeed into the notion
but at first into picture thinking into
the synthetic linking together of
self-conscious and external existence
the external existence of this picture
thinking language is the earliest
language the epic as such which contains
the universal content of the world
universal at least in the sense of
completeness though not indeed as the
universality of thought
the minstrel
is the individual an actual spirit from
whom as a subject of this world the
world is produced and by whom it is born
his pathos is not the stupefying power
of nature but nesume recollection and a
gradually developed inwardness the
remembrance of essence that formerly was
directly present
he is the organ that vanishes in its
content
what counts is not his own self but his
muse his universal song
what however is in fact present is the
syllogism
in which the extreme of universality the
world of the gods is linked with
individuality with the minstrel through
the middle term of particularity
the middle term is the nation and its
heroes who are individual men like the
minstrel but presented only in idea and
are thereby at the same time universal
like the free extreme of universality
the gods
there is a lot of important stuff going
on in this paragraph
729 we get introduced to
let's call him a new character the
minstrel or zinger the bard is another
way we could translate this the composer
and the composer of what even more
important than the minstrel
is this particular use of language in a
poetic
framework that is the epic and epic
poetry we're thinking for example of
homer's
odyssey and iliad but we could think of
many other epic poems as well
and they are indeed poetry they they are
not simply
prose cool stories that are being told
they have a structure to them
and they are a form of what hegel here
is going to call
picture thinking or for stellang
as
they are also language and we should
think back to
the previous subsection i've mentioned
this several times already we ended the
the previous subsection the living work
of art by invoking
a new kind of language that would be
more adequate than that of the hymn or
the oracle or of the frenzy well what is
that it's going to be for the greeks and
also for so many other people's
poetry poetry present in the form of
epic and we should pause for a second
what is an epic you know we use that
term a lot oh man that's epic no that's
not the same thing right or this is an
epic story when what we really mean is
this is a
cool drama you know uh we talk about
epic fantasy as well and quite frankly
epic fantasy if we have in mind say
george r martin
or you know j.r tolkien
or
you know pick whoever else you want is
not quite the same thing as epic that
word epic as an adjective is different
than the epic as a noun the epic is a
long poem
that may seem to lack an internal
overarching unity but actually does have
it and it's provided by
the things that the gods and the heroes
the human beings are
involved in
so
many cultures produce these
they are
poetry in greek and latin poetry it has
to do with the amount of syllables and
where the stresses are and whether
they're long or short that's how the
rhyme structure works and the same thing
goes by the way for tragedy
as well so he he tells us
here we go
that same the same universality which
belongs to this content what content
that in discussed in the previous
paragraph the content of dealing with
the gods attaches necessarily also to
the
form
of consciousness in which the content
appears so the form of consciousness
this is very important
what are we talking about there are we
just talking about is it consciousness
or self-consciousness no we're talking
about the way in which things are
[Music]
grasped understood perhaps
conceptualized or not
and very often in discussing religion
in
his lectures on the philosophy of
religion it's going to be moving from
feeling full
uh or perception to
foreshadowing picture thinking
representation then up to concept or
notion as miller translates it by grief
right and this is not an
absolute like there's dividing lines
here and here and you like cross the
threshold it's much more complicated
than that right you can have four
stellang that's much more you know
foreshtellingy than others that are
close some that are closer to the grit
some that are more
infected with gefoul feeling affectivity
here he's not actually bringing up
affectivity or geful as the
thing that that foreshowing transcends
he's talking about something different
practice now
miller translates
this as actual practice the tune
of the cult
handling would be closer to practice
but tun can work as well provided we're
understanding it as a sequence of doing
similar things
over and over again right that can be a
han lung
so we have an actual practice of the
cult that it's that bad right it's not
like it's not religious but we're going
to transcend it through this new form of
language in the epoch he says it's a
practice that is raised not yet indeed
into the notion
that's going to happen later on
but
into picture thinking
and here he says something really
interesting about picture thinking
doesn't he
what is picture thinking he's using a
term here
as a little bit of a digression
and also a little bit of a rant
so
by now you're all familiar with the
notion of
thesis antithesis synthesis and you
probably know that hegel doesn't
actually talk about things in that that
framework he does often talk about
things that we can translate as
antithesis but it doesn't always lead to
a synthesis the hegelian three step is
actually the product of
you know reductive attitudes towards
hegel sometimes superstitious uh
sometimes fearful
in general just silly
this is one of the rare points in the
phenomenology of spirit where he uses
that third term
but he doesn't say synthesis
what does he actually say
a synthetic all right so putting things
together synthetic
linking together
of
what of self-conscious
and external existence and existence
here is design right self-conscious is
an adjective here external is an
adjective here so of of two
kinds of design being brought together
synthetically that is bringing them
together positing them together linking
them together
as
one
with you know these two sides
self-conscious and external oyster
so
this is actually you know kind of an
interesting curiosity let's go on though
before that so this this is what he says
picture thinking actually is
foreshadowing is
but then he says the external existence
of this picture thinking
what is that
language
do we think of language as an external
existence
well we should because it was there
before we were born and we were born
into a language which then we learned
how to use and obviously we took that
language and transformed it within
ourselves
right
self-consciously quite often in relation
to other self-consciousness but it
preceded
us and we appropriate what is there so
he says that the external existence of
this picture thinking language is the
earliest language
the epic as such now he's not saying
this is the earliest language per se
right it's not as if human beings uh you
know whenever they manage to come out of
the complete savagery that they they
were in uh you know as proto-humans that
they immediately started speaking and
epic right no that's that's not the case
look at the sentence more closely he
says
the epoch is such which contains the
universal content of the world this is
the earliest language which contains the
universal content of the world universal
at least in the sense of completeness
though not indeed as the universality of
thought it's not yet conceptuality but
the epic hegel is saying is the earliest
language which contains a kind of
totality
of the world and you might say well
how is that the case it presents
a certain
narrative
complex narrative
as
a finished product as the
story of an era
is it really complete no i mean think
about the odyssey uh so odysseus is
stuck on an island with this goddess
calypso
for what about six seven years and we
know that he cries every once in a while
and he misses his home and calypso loves
him and they
get it on and and he's moping around do
we know what he ate on you know
day
655 of his captivity was it was it fish
was it nuts was it fruit was it maybe
all three
we don't know
you know you don't have to have a
exhaustive discussion of every single
thing to have a
coherent and complete narrative
it's
sort of the
nitpickers who who want that all the
time you know we see similar things with
like the gospels right what was jesus
doing before you know how much did he
charge when he he engaged in carpenter
who the hell cares it doesn't matter
it's not part of the story right
do you like figs
he said that bad thing about a fig tree
once i don't know you know what's going
on with that you know we could we could
quibble about that sort of stuff there
is a completeness that's there in an
epic right
and it can be added to as a matter of
fact epics do develop over time as we
know
but there's a
this is sufficient to it so he goes on
and he says the universal content of the
world universal in the sense of
completeness and now he says something
really interesting he brings in this
character the minstrel the zanger the
minstrel is the individual an actual
spirit a geist a mind
from whom
as a subject of this world
the world is produced
now that is worth dwelling on
the minstrel exists
as a
human being as an individual
within the language of these society the
culture the folk that they are a part of
and that's the condition for being able
to make the epic right and you know if
we extend this further
intergenerationally you know we think
that homer wasn't
a single guy who came up with all this
stuff all by himself we think they were
actually traditions going back a long
way and we could call it like a you know
intergenerational building towards these
epic poems and we can say similar things
about other epics as well
so the minstrel is
working within the language and then
they're also
expanding the language
in how they're using it to extend it to
this world this narrative world the
world is produced and by whom it is born
now notice what else hegel says here his
pathos what is undergoing is not the
stupefying power of nature this is
something going out of nature this is
culture now but a mnesomne memory
recollection and a gradually developed
inwardness
this is worth pausing out too
what allows the bard the minstrel the
composer to be able to generate
characters
many characters
of different orientations
who have an interiority
his own interiority
and this means that the bard in a
certain sense
has to be
more than just a single
person who's totally unified in their
perspective they have to make space
within themselves and within their
language
for these gods and heroes
and and others who they bring in
cowards you know
uh
people selling things whoever else it's
going to be
so he goes on and he says the
remembrance of essence
that we formally was directly present in
formally directly present in the cult
right
he is the organ that vanishes in its
content what counts is not his own self
but his muse his universal song what do
we know about homer not much what do we
know about a lot of these
people who produce epics or produce
other compositions we know what they
have in their compositions and we're
sometimes tempted to identify them with
one of their characters right
that's often a mistake that's a mistake
by the way not just for homer but for
shakespeare for dostoevsky as scholars
have pointed out perhaps even for borges
so he goes on now he brings up a
syllogism when we have a hegelian
reference to syllogism think connected
uh reasoning process that also has a
metaphysical aspect to it mediation is
taking place we have a mitta uh sort of
like we in the previous paragraph we had
a middle point now we have a mita a
means a connector between them so what
is the syllogism here we have a
syllogism with extremes of universality
and extremes of individuality and they
are linked through the middle term of
particularity
so what are these extremes the extreme
of universality is the world of the gods
the
folk geistered right the the gods of the
people that have been brought together
now into a pantheon
which has a ruler but not a
emperor or power structure and
bureaucracy or anything like that on the
other side we have the individuality
of the bard who does manage to sometimes
interject a little reference to himself
in there but who's being lost in the
composition and the middle point of it
is what
the nation in its heroes
the nation and its heroes not just
everybody
we're not trying to have a realistic
depiction of social life the way that
you know cultural and social historians
might want to generate for us this is a
different kind of language we care about
what you know heracles is doing or jason
or
achilles and agamemnon and we also care
about what the gods do you know like
when achilles is thinking
this friggin egg him i'm not i'm just
gonna like
kill him i'm gonna kill this guy and
athena you know uh is helping out or you
know when athena on the other hand ajax
is mad at odysseus and athena's like
yeah you should go kill him as a matter
of fact i'm also going to take your
brain out so that you think you're
torturing odysseus when you're torturing
a sheep this will be shameful for you so
this middle term the heroes is is very
important and he says that they are
individual like the minstrel but
presented only an idea and are thereby
universal like the free extreme of
universality of the gods
this is what happens in epic poetry this
is what hegel is depicting here and this
is a way for us to now connect with the
gods through a different kind
of language something that's in advance
something that's a development it's not
yet conceptual
but it is
quite an advanced
you